الان ومعنا من مستشفى الشفاء في المدينه
مراسل الجزيره اسماعيل الغول مرحبا بك
اسماعيل واليوم في غزه قصف خلف عددا كبيرا
من الشهداء والمصابين في حي
الزيتون اجمل لنا التفاصيل هذا القصف وا
الاوضاع في غزه بشكل
عامله نعم هو استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي
على مدينه غزه لكن هذه المره بشكل مركز
على البنا السكنيه الماهوله والممتلئ
بالنازحين والسكان العزل صباح هذا اليوم
وفجر هذا اليوم قصفت قوات الاحتلال منزلين
ماهول بالسكان احدى هذه المنازل في منطقه
الثلاثين قرب مفترق المغربي يتبع لعائله
السوسي وسقط في هذا المنزل 15 اصابه و20
شهيدا وفق ما اعلن الدفاع المدني
وانتشل ان 80% من الشهداء هم اطفال داخل
هذا المنزل تم قصف المنزل دون تحذير مسبق
او دون صاروخ مثلا استطلاع كما هو يتم
مثلا في المرات او مرات سابقه لكن تم قصف
المنزل بعده صواريخ من طائرات الاف 16
بشكل مباشر مما ادى الى سقوط 20 شهيدا
وصلوا الى مجمع الشفاء الطبي صباح هذا
اليوم بالاضافه الى ذلك قصف قوات الاحتلال
في منطقه الشمعه منطقه الزيتون منزلا من
ثلاث طوابق وهذا المنزل هو بالاساس من سته
طوابق لكن لم ينفجر الصاروخ الثاني لو
انفجر هذا الصاروخ وقدر الله انه لم ينفجر
ل سقط عدد اكبر من الشهداء سقط في هذا
المنزل 11 شهيدا هو منزل يتبع لعائله
الحداد واصابتان وصلا الى مجمع الشفاء
الطبي هذا المنزل حتى هذه اللحظه يتم
التعامل من قبل وحدات الهندسه ل حتى لا
ينفجر الصاروخ الثاني وحتى هذه اللحظات
ايضا المنزل الذي يتبع لعائله السوسي يتم
انتشال الشهداء من اسفل الانقاظ الذين
تبقوا تحت الثلاث طوابق هذه المشهد
المتكرر على مدينه غزه قصف متواصل وانتشال
شهداء متواصل بالاضافه الى ذلك وصل عدد من
الشهداء من منطقه شرق الشجاعيه حتى هذه
اللحظات تحاول اهالي انتشال الشهداء الذين
تبقوا اسفل الانقاظ منذ ما يزيد عن 30
يوما وانتهاء العمليه العسكريه في ذاك
المكان تواصل الاهالي انتشال ابنائها من
اسفل القضه الذين بقوا الايام طويله جدا
وهذا السبب يعود الى ان وحدات الدفاع
المدني دمرت 70% من قدراتها التي وهذه
القدرات هي قدرات الامكانات مثل البواخر
والجرافات والمعدات الثقيله التي يتم من
خلالها انتشال الشهداء بالاضافه الى ذلك
صعوبه وصول سيارات الاسعاف بسبب الدمار
الكبير في الشوارع والبنيه التحديه وتجريف
قوات الاحتلال لكل الشوارع المتواجده في
المناطق الشرقيه وبالتحديد منطقه شرق
الزيتون ومنطقه شرق حي الشجاعيه هذه
المناطق التي تعتبر مدمره بالكامل
ومجرفة ولهفه المواطنون في انتظار شاحنات
المساعدات التي تاتي من جنوب قطاع غزه الى
شمال عبر ممر الشيخ عجلين ولكن قوات
الاحتلال دائما ما تضرب حشود الجماهير
والمواطنين المنتظره لدخول الشاحنات وهذا
ما يتسبب بوصول عدد كبير من الاصابات
والشهداء الى مجمع الشفاء الطبي على مدار
الساعات الصباحيه في ظل دخول المساعدات
يعني اسماعيل افدتنا قبل قليل بالحصي
نتحدث عن اكثر من 30 شهيد فقط في مدينه
غزه منذ الصباح بفعل القصف في منطقه
الثلاثين وكذلك الزيتون هذا العدد الكبير
من الشهداء وكذلك من الاصابات كيف يتم
التعامل معه في
مستشفى الشفاء الذي يراد له ان ان يعمل
بطريقه طبيعيه بعد ما جرى
[موسيقى]
فيه اذا ما تحدثنا عن طريقه التعامل في
مستشفى الشفاء فيتم التعامل ب ادنى
القدرات جميع من يتواجد او جل من يتواجد
في مجمع الشفاء الطبي هم متطوعين وحديثي
التخرج بعد ان اجلت قوات الاحتلال الطاقم
الطبي في مجمع الشفاء الطبي الى جنوب قطاع
غزه حينما كان محاصرا لكن هذه ال الطواقم
المتواجده تتعامل بكل قدراتها وزاره الصحه
المتبقيه في شمال قطاع غزه حاولت تشغيل
بعض غرف العمليات وتم تشغيل غرفتي عمليات
وجهاز سيتي وجهاز اشعه وهذا ما يساعد
الطواقم الطبيه المتواجده على الرغم من
محدوديه عددها وهذا يسبب
ضغطا كبيرا على الطواقم على مدار الساعه
انها تتعامل مع الاصابات لكن تحاول وزاره
الصحه بشكل مستمر على انقاذ حياه الجرحه
الذين يسقطوا في هذا القصف الاسرائيلي
المتواصل رغم عدم وجود كوادر طبيه كافيه
وايضا مستلزمات طبيه ومعدات طبيه كافيه
ايضا في مجمع الشفاء الطبي لكن تحاول
الوزاره بشكل مستمر اسعاف ما تبقى
واستنهاض بما تبقى من المعدات والطواقم
الطبيه المتبقيه